and this directly goes against what Joe
Biden said in the debate in 2020 with
Donald Trump take a listen
my son has not made money in terms of
this thing about what are you talking
about China what did you not of that
President he made a fortune in Ukraine
in China in that is simply various other
places
so it's from two different debates but I
mean Trump was right I mean he did make
a fortune from China and Joe Biden was
wrong I don't know that he was lying
about it he might not have been told by
Hunter but this blind spot is a problem
it's a problem one because Republicans
aren't going to let it go that's for
sure that's the problem the problem is
these Republicans keep talking about it
actually in their mind that is the
problem and this is why I say it's only
sort of nice to see the Liberals admit
they were wrong because this is an
extremely
calculated admission